- [Interviewer] All right, Clara.
Clara, where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I was raised in Portland,
Oregon until I left.
I was 11 when I left.
- [Interviewer] Did you grow
up with both parents or what?
- I grew up with a stepfather.
I did meet my first, my father,
he tried to have sex
with me, my blood father.
But I had already been molested, so,
it didn't bother me as much as some things
later in life bother me a little bit more.
- [Interviewer] What age
did he start molesting you?
- I met my father when my mother
got with another pedophile
who could not have female
minors living in the home.
He had just raped his blood daughter
and he had gotten released.
He's dead now, name was Manuel
Lona, and he was on parole,
could not have female
minors living in the house.
So, I went to live with my
Grammy who I was very close with,
and my mom called my dad, who
was in Nevada, Lemmon Valley.
And he came out there, drove
out there, he was on drugs.
I knew what it was from, like, TV shows,
but I had never seen
somebody actually do it.
He had his fourth wife, she was pregnant,
he has about 12 kids, I guess
half-brothers and sisters
of me, I don't know them.
My father's wife went into labor,
she went to the hospital
and he went with her.
There was only two small children there,
Destiny, who's supposedly, it's rumored
that he killed, my
half-sister Destiny, her mama.
They got into a fight and she pulled a gun
and he struggled, there
was a struggle for the gun.
The gun went off, she got
shot, Destiny was there.
They took Destiny away, put him in jail,
pending the charges.
They said it was self-defense
but when she was shot,
he had plenty of time to
call an ambulance for her.
He waited until she bled
out and then he called.
That's what I heard.
So, when she went into labor,
the next wife, fourth wife,
went into labor with Christopher
James, that's my brother,
he came back home to the house.
I was asleep, I played like I was asleep
'cause my other, my step-daddy,
when I was a little girl,
all the time, he'd pick me
up and carry me to my bed
so I would just pretend like I was asleep.
And the only reason I
knew it wasn't my bed
was 'cause it was a water bed.
And he says, "you want me
to take those clothes off
and show you something
really nice? Just turn over".
Well, I scurried out of
there like a bat out of hell
and ran over to my room, the
rooms were next to each other.
It was in Nevada and I locked the door
and I thought about going
out the window but I didn't,
and then the next day he put
me on a bus back to Oregon.
He didn't want me telling nobody I guess.
Didn't call nobody either.
When I got there, it was
in the middle of the night.
I had to walk all the way to my Grammy's.
Downtown Portland, Oregon,
the 33rd and Prescott.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Yup, I've been through a lot.
On my way out of Oregon, I
met a pimp named Charlie Soft.
He took me down here by
Disneyland and told me to make-
[Interviewer] What age?
- I was 12 when I first started.
By 15, I had met Memphis Slim.
Memphis Slim, I fell in love with him
but I don't think he loved anybody, ever.
He was more about money,
money, money, money, money.
He was sometimes, I'd come home,
Hell, one day I made $500 in two hours.
I see him driving by, I flagged him down,
I said, "I can take the whole
day off, look what I got!"
And he said, "Go on and
get the rest of that $500."
I said, "What?"
He said, "It don't look like it to me,
let me count it again,
no that's only $200."
It was $500.
But he would never take
it from hand-to-hand.
You had to set it down
somewhere and he'd pick it up.
We had an apartment
out here in Studio City
but we never did get a steel refrigerator.
Wouldn't have mattered, I
couldn't cook at that age.
I was pregnant by him, he
had me have an abortion.
I had my first one, I was
pregnant by him twice.
I had my first abortion
by him in Encenido?
Encenida, I think it was called.
And in Colorado Springs, where his brother
was actually arrested for
pimping and pandering.
His brother, his whole family,
was in the pimp and ho game.
They have a talk that's
different than English,
it's like Pig Latin.
It's like, if I was to say, "Who are you?"
It'd be like, "His-nu, his-nu, his-nu?"
"Who are you?"
Like, up and down, "dis-nau, dis-nau",
it's pimp-ho talk, it's a language.
- [Interviewer] So, where did your life go
from there, after you were with the pimp?
- I came back to California.
I became a South Sider from
West Side Huerfanos, orphans.
I'm from OPHS, my name is Tradia Sanjo.
And I gang-banged for quite some time
because nobody sees me coming, allegedly.
(laughs)
But, yeah, and then I got with Michael,
well no, I got with
Cartoon, my homeboy, first,
and had my daughter, my daughter's by him.
And then I met Michael.
I got out of prison after serving
13 years on a 15-year sentence.
I was accused of doing 36 armed
robberies, being the driver.
Many of them were dismissed.
I took a plea deal, my
co-defendant took 20 years.
Came back down, gave detailed testimony
and signed affidavit
and watched the hearing.
Because of that, they dropped
his time from 20 to 12.
I had to take the deal, I
could not fight it any longer
because I would have been
convicted and got a life sentence.
So, I served 13 years flat.
I hit all three prisons,
I paroled from EOP,
which is in CIW.
I just recently got off parole, yay to me!
- [Interviewer] First time?
- No, second time.
But the first time,
they were so far apart!
I forgot about the penalty,
I'll never forget again.
13 years flat will wake you up.
My son was five months old,
my daughter had just turned
five the month before.
- [Interviewer] So you have two kids?
- I have two.
My son is raised by his father
who is, well, Hell, I might
as well be honest about it.
He's my mother-in-law's husband.
And we had sex on the sofa
and I produced a son from it.
I regret it, I love her,
I don't know how I did it.
I'm messed up in the head, I
don't do things the right way.
I love Raina and I know Raina loves me.
I told her recently how sorry I was.
But I think she-
- [Interviewer] You were-
- Father-in-law.
- [Interviewer] Father-in-law.
So where are you living now?
- I live in a tent.
I got with Michael, Michael
brought me down here.
I'd never been past this
side of the freeway before.
My neighborhood when I
banged was over in that area.
I've also prostituted recently
because I have to support myself.
It's very hard, especially,
it's getting ready to rain,
I have no top, my tent
has no door that closes,
I have to put something in front of it.
I have to have a big tent.
I can't be bending over,
trying to scoot on stuff.
I've got diabetic neuropathy
and I'm old as dirt.
So, trying to save up
and get me a big tent.
- [Interviewer] How old are you turning?
- I will be 50 in March,
can you believe it?
- [Interviewer] And you've
been walking the streets,
turning tricks for how many decades?
- Ooh, Lord, I quit for
a long time, stop it now!
(laughs)
I'm not telling my secrets.
- [Interviewer] You started
as a young teenager.
- Yes, I did.
I was actually, I was
just telling you recently,
I took a Greyhound bus, Memphis
Slim put me on a Greyhound
to go to the Olympics in
Vancouver, B.C., Canada.
Now, this was in the '80s,
it had to have been '85,
I think, '85 or '86, or
'84, one of those years.
- [Interviewer] So you'd make money-
- Oh, yes.
I made a ton of money
there, Lord, way bigger.
I mean, you think you've made a lot more,
but then they change it,
and then you change it,
and it's only half of what
you got in the beginning.
Similar to that.
Same thing down in Mexico.
I've never been there, scared to go there.
I drove through it though, oh,
I met this cute little thing,
couldn't speak no English.
He spoke no English, I
couldn't speak no Spanish
at the time, now I can
speak it almost fluently.
But he wanted to home, so,
"I'll drive you," I said.
I drove him through Tijuana
all the way to Mexico de efe
where I couldn't go no further.
The car blew up and he had to go one way
and I went the other.
I called the American Consulate
and they gave me the money
to get a ride back to TJ.
This was actually during the time
that the metros here was on strike.
So, I was stuck down there
at the Greyhound station.
And then somebody, for a watch,
gave me a ride out to South Central.
I've lived in South Central
since I quit gang-banging.
It's been many, many years.
- [Interviewer] What's the craziest story
you can tell about your life in there?
- I asked a guy for some food.
He told me he'd take me to McDonald's
right around the corner
from where I'm living.
He pulled over, said "Check your thing".
I turned to look at, "What thing?".
The man grabbed me by the
neck and tried to kill me.
If I had not had rotated
my body with the way
he was rotating my neck,
he would have broke it.
By the time I rotated my body,
I had gotten my knife out and I sliced
his motherfucking ass so hard,
I know he had to have stitches.
But he wanted to hurt me and
I will only use a weapon now
to hurt people I don't
like, liars, thieves.
I don't do anything that I
don't want done to me anymore.
So, I don't put out no bad karma.
So, if I did put something out to you
and you're watching, I apologize.
I've changed.
That's about it.
- [Interviewer] Clara,
it feels amazing talking.
Thank you for your life story.
- All right.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Darling, that was perfect.
- [Clara] Was it?
- [Interviewer] You did perfect!
- [Clara] You thought I couldn't do it.
- [Interviewer] I know you can talk.
- [Clara] I know I can,
'cause nobody listens to me!
- [Interviewer] We're at 10
minutes, I told you five.